este saque de esquina es una victoria
para este equipo aficionado de raqqa
durante los tres años que el estado
islámico tuvo el control de la ciudad
era impensable un partido de amigos como
éste
esto significa mucho para nosotros en
ese momento nuestra rutina era trabajar
y la casa no había la capacidad para
hacer deporte ni la tranquilidad mental
para practicarlo
y si es prohibía cualquier actividad
lúdica incluido la televisión los libros
y el fútbol
la librería de ajmán siempre fue la
preferida de los intelectuales cuando
hice estuvo el control de la ciudad las
nuevas autoridades aseguraron que sus
libros eran inmorales él les dijo que
hicieran lo que quisieran con ellos
prefería salvar su vida les dije que era
viejo incluso si removían las paredes y
las quemaban no me iba a importar
inválida frank
hoy esta librería apenas tiene unos
cuantos títulos para kinect se queja de
que pocos quieren leer pero aún así
quiera volver a ofrecer la mejor
variedad de títulos de la ciudad es casi
imposible traer libros harraca es muy
difícil porque estamos casi bajo embargo
estos pocos libros vienen de
instituciones
en esta plazoleta de naím que
decapitaron cientos de personas pero la
nueva generación busca dejar atrás este
dolor
somos estudiantes de instituto estamos
en descanso y venimos a divertirnos
estos jóvenes se atreven a bailar en
público pero no hablar del pasado
especialmente de los tiempos de isis
no no hablaré que hable otro
el futuro de raqqa como el de siria es
incierto pero aquí muchos están
dispuestos a seguir luchando por sus
pequeños espacios de libertad